I feel like if there was ever a
conspiracy to try and launch a book a
ton of free speech furors at some of
America's highest education institutions
might very well be it so I'm not saying
that you and Greg started all of this
stuff off but I am saying that it seems
to be conveniently timed yeah um I we
convinced all of the IV leagan elite
institutions to just self-detonate
exactly as we were dropping this book
about how terrible and dire the state of
free speech is on their campus and the
state of discourse so it's been an
interesting time for sure also often an
unideal time to be a vocal free speech
absolutist um because it requires that
you defend speech that is often very
heinous even in the depths of an
unfolding crisis um but certainly I
think we're seeing the the consequences
of Decades of just the these major elite
institutions in America just abdicating
the value of free speech completely
throwing it to the way side and then
allowing radicalism and and some really
frightening liberal Tendencies to fester
in its place what has happened to the
rates of calls for cancellation over the
last few
years it's been absolutely staggering
and since
2014 um fire which is my my co-author
Greg lukanov is the the president of the
foundation for individual rights and
expression and they've tallied more than
a thousand attempts to get professors
fired 200 of which have been successful
in getting them sanctioned um and that
actually is twice the rate of the uh 10
years that roughly constitute what
McCarthyism was and so if we're looking
back in historical context we look at
that as a horrendous blate on our record
as a country in terms of you know firing
people for ideological reasons and we
are now outstripping that at roughly
twice the pace so I think in the future
historians will be looking back at this
moment in time and studying it much as
we did um and rightfully so the
1950s what is driving this increase why
is it ramping up so much what are the
the undercurrents that are causing this
thing to happen yeah so I think the the
major Catalyst here and why we Define
cancel culture as starting in 2014 and
its modern iteration is because social
media allows it to just take off like
wildfire and we um we kind of refer to
Richard Dawkins is idea of a meme
because cancel culture is very uh it's
very effective you know you don't have
to actually engage with some some's
argument you just attack them ad hominum
you make an example of them you make
sure that no one else wants to tread the
same ideological path as them and in the
end people see that and watch that and
replicate that and I think that social
media has allowed for an unprecedented
amount of scrutiny on institutions ideas
and people which of course is a good
thing however we're in one of those like
post printing press moments of social
unrest where we haven't yet figured out
how to navigate this world in which now
billions of people are in the cultural
conversation and um and anyone could be
to torn down at any moment
unceremoniously fairly unfairly and so I
think you know this is our book is a an
attempt to call attention to the issue
and also um hopefully get more people on
board to figuring out how we get out of
this mess because I think that there
actually is a lot of um just general
desire and a general understanding that
that things have gone too far that
people are walking on eggshells and that
that's not a healthy way to live right
so if you're saying that the
distribution mechanism of social media
frictionless free communication
ubiquitous instantly globally accessible
that is that's almost like the delivery
mechanism driving the virus in some way
is there anything deeper than that or is
the main driver of this just the fact
that humans have perverse incentives
there are a bunch of strange things that
go on in our psychology and when the
opportunity arises is to be able to do
this it activates something inside of us
or has there been a deeper cultural
change too that's driven the
cancellation increase yeah I mean I
think that the this the seeds have been
sewn for decades here where we've just
seen a general um institutional creep
away from Free Speech values a
generational creep as well um and we we
definitely believe that cancel culture
started in its um kind of fledging form
on American campuses in the 80s and 90s
when the first wave of political
correctness was coming around like Bill
was doing the politically incorrect show
before I was even born and it was kind
of laughable at that point in time but
then all of a sudden as soon as social
media came onto the Forefront and jenzie
unfortunately my generation came to
college campuses and began
unceremoniously shouting down and
tearing down their professors um it
exploded out into the open in a way that
it hadn't really historically however um
the the creep away from classical
liberal values has been consistent um
and you know one thing that was really
frightening writing this book is
realizing how different Greg my
co-author is um nearing 50 and I'm 23 so
we have totally different generational
span and the the old idioms and kind of
um kind of foundational principles of
American society that he grew up with
like to each his own and Sticks and
Stones I wasn't raised with any of them
um we I was I was raised with words can
wound you and um oppressed people need
to be protected and and you need to be
the the warrior to step in on their
behalf L they be offended and it's just
a fundamental flip and I think that as a
culture we've just moved more towards
protectionism and and a feeling that
we're all feeble rather than this
resilient sort of anti- fragile
framework that used to be kind of core
to to the American Spirit I think it's
the British it's the British Spirit too
you know like stiff up a lip that's what
we were known for the stiff up a lip and
you know um musn't Grumble musn't
Grumble things are going badly but
musn't Grumble uh yeah
there's a increase in fragility right a
rampant
fragility but it's not it's Hollow
because it's not like there's an actual
change people are living longer than
ever before people have got better
health care than ever before you're more
able to deal with anything from the car
accident to the bad weather to the heat
to the cold to whatever it is so it's
odd that you
have real world situations going in One
Direction whilst perceptions of how bad
it is going in another
but just how bad is it now like what
what stats have you found to back up
just how many people are being cancelled
or or what the the sense the cultural
therometer is saying yeah I mean fire
does these tremendous surveys of student
sentiment around the country and we know
that roughly two-thirds of students on
college campuses say that they're
self-censoring um we also know that
roughly 90% of professors say the same
and that one and 10 have been
investigated for what their what should
be protected speech um and so I think
that one of the things that's
interesting is there there tends to
consistently be es and flows of cancel
culture where people say oh it's behind
us and like it's no it's no longer an
issue 2016 was a rough moment but like
now we're back to normal and then the
pandemic happens and it's even worse in
the wake of 2020 and then oh no maybe
we're back to normal and then the Israel
Palestine conflict erupts and it's just
anytime there's a moment of social
unrest a a culture that is not actually
deeply rooted in its Free Speech values
will tend towards a liberalism
censorship um attacking disagre or
denters from the predominant Viewpoint
and I think that we see that time and
again and every single time it's been
getting more severe so if you look at
the case loads that fire um gets from
students and faculty across the country
uh 2020 was a record-breaking year
despite the fact that kids weren't even
on campuses so they had an unprecedented
case load and you know if you also look
at the the raw statistics of the surveys
of of Americans consistently roughly
four and five Americans will agree that
political correctness has gone too far
that cancel culture is a problem that
they feel that they have to self-censor
and I think it's genuinely a tyranny of
the minority it's just the problem is
that that remaining 20% squeaky Wheels
who actually do tear people down have
such an outsized impact on society where
we're all self-censoring and I felt that
myself being an NYU student in the the
recent past for sure what was your
experience on campus like when you got
there I had gone to a um a boarding
school that was almost like a mini
College before so I feel like I was kind
of primed by the time I arrived at NYU
um my freshman year of high school was
the first time that I realized I just
did not agree with the the prevailing
Viewpoint um when they on Martin Luther
King day is put all the kids in
different buildings based on their race
to talk about their racial experience
and I remember being like this is kind
of the opposite of how I've been taught
to uh internalize the the lessons of
Martin Luther King Jr and um yeah so
that was I Knew by the time I arrived at
NYU that I was uh kind of going against
the grain and when I did get there I
was understandably I think in retrospect
concerned for my social standing and so
I was hiding Thomas Soul books and
Jordan Peterson books under my bad which
is really embarrassing in retrospect and
like now I've been on Jordan's podcast
and I'm super cancelled and you know
booted from every group chat that I was
in basically at NYU but um it was
generally a an ideologically oppressive
environment I would say I I rarely heard
dissenting viewpoints um I took I I did
a two years of a Humanities degree
before dropping out despite having a 4.0
GPA because you know full tuition for
Zoom school was not going to happen um
but I would say that generally it was
one way or the highway kids would even
try occasionally to pop into
philosophical conversations and say you
know to play Devil's Advocate and then
present some unpopular opinion and they
would literally be scoffed and hissed at
consistently so um I would it just it
made me self- censor and I realized once
I started writing for the New York Post
and being outspoken finally in the
pandemic that so many people around me
reached out to me privately and said you
know I I completely agree with you and
I've been in a class with them and I
would never have known because you know
cancel culture and liberalism thrives by
making everyone feel alone but even at a
school like NYU there there were a
considerable number of kids who actually
did feel similarly oppressed but um or
ideologically oppressed but didn't feel
that they could speak out and and didn't
have any examples around them it's
strange to think if that's the case 66%
of students are self-censoring in some
form or another on campus but that there
will be a good chunk of those students
that will hiss and and mock if you try
to even steal man let alone actually
have a different opinion I know it seems
like it's it's I'm wondering what is
motivating those people to be so
vehement in their enforcement of a
particular ideology that 66% of them
don't agree with or at least have
criticisms of like what's the I'm trying
to work out what's the incentive what
what's in it for the counselor m well I
think that the the there's like a kind
of cluster B personality type that's
really been um empowered on campuses I
think and and people who are I think
genuine Believers at a place like NYU I
there are a considerable fraction of
people who who generally believe that if
they step in on behalf of some you know
oppressed theoretical group that might
be offended by something that you say
which by the way they're almost never
the demographic of people that they're
defending but I think that there's moral
High Ground to it and um and and a sense
of righteousness and I I would even go
as far as to say like a bit of like a a
religious kind of attitude towards it
like I I think of John mccarter's book
woke racism and and the idea that um
this is kind of supplanting this like
this ideology in a in a post Faith world
is often times occupying that same part
of the the human psyche I would say um
but also it's so institutionalized at
these colleges as well I think that even
even if not every Professor agrees with
it certainly the administrators are
extremely disproportionately leftwing or
left leaning and when I was at NYU for
example we on the back of our ID cards
it says here's 911 here's the phone
number for the campus police which you
probably could theoretically need it in
New York City at any point in time and
here's the the Student Health Center and
all these emergency numbers and then
also the bias response hotline where you
could call if you felt grieved or
offended by something that someone said
and it's a literally an
institutionalized snitch culture on
these campuses and it was literally on
the back of the bathroom stalls too
they'd have like posters of like has
something happened to you call the bias
response hotline and you're you know
immediately on the phone with an
administrator so I you're walking on
eggshells and even if it is just a small
percentage of kids who will hiss or who
will
call you any sort of iser ism um or a
phobe at any any opportunity just one
kid doing that is enough to shut an
entire class down I believe and I I saw
it
firsthand yeah it's a a very
effective leverage one person that has
that what's that um panopticon it's kind
of like the panopticon right that you
have one person that's able to be in the
middle and manipulate an awful lot of
people around the
opinions and the
fear it's a race to the bottom in that
regard like Whoever has the most the
highest Purity level is the one whose
opinion is is going to continue to be
pushed forward what was that analysis of
mass Twitter bands that you guys love
yeah they found um this is this is data
that we got from the national contagion
Research Institute and they followed the
growth of the platform gab as Twitter
did Mass bans and purges of accounts
that were um at various times associated
with like Infowars or um there were I
think post Charlottesville there were
groups of um that they' identified as
white supremacists and proud boys and
they would do these Mass bans and purges
of accounts starting around 2016 and
then literally in lockstep there would
be a mass Exodus to gab every single
time and that the percentage of uh of
gabs that included the word ban would go
up by like a factor of 10 and so we we
analyzed that data basically to
demonstrate that when we do fight ideas
that could be very offensive and
unsavory and and I I understand why
people are offended by white supremacist
views and proud boy views I'm not
defending them however when you remove
them from from the the common square in
places where they might interact with
other viewpoints or where they might get
quote tweeted and publicly shamed you
end up creating even deeper more
entrenched Echo Chambers and so we were
very fortunate to get this data from NCI
because we now can provably say that
censorship does not make these ideas go
away it just puts them into more obscure
crevices of the internet where people
are more likely to agree and have a
positive feedback loop so um we we were
extremely fortunate that that had not
been published before um we had done
this book and and I think it's a a
demonstration of the importance of a
platform actually tacking towards free
speech because those views are not gone
they're just somewhere else and none of
us hear about them but they very much
exist in in another crevice of the
internet what do you think cancellation
is trying to achieve like what you just
explained there it doesn't seem to work
it pushes these ideas underground in
some regard it can throw them into Echo
Chambers where there are presumably no
dissenting voices what what is it trying
to
achieve I mean I think it's just
predicated on a think a fundamental
misunderstanding of how how dialogue
works and how minds are changed in
hearts and and minds are one over I
think I think there's been such a an
alienation from the classical liberal
values post Enlightenment that that made
society free and and made dialogue
robust and made debate healthy and um in
the realm of ideas and not ad homenum
and you know for for example I I've
never learned John Stewart Mills on
Liberty I never learned the importance
of free speech and growing up even going
to Great Schools and doing a Philosophy
degree at NYU I didn't understand the
importance and and just how profound
those post Enlightenment ideals are and
how much they need to be bought into by
the entire culture and community in
order to thrive and I think that those
some people who engage in cancel culture
are genuinely meped but other people I
think do believe that if they shut down
and I don't know castigate anybody who
has a bad belief that that somehow
actually does expunge it from society
which is provably untrue I think it's
it's polarized us even further um but I
I do think that it's just because people
are are no longer taught the the
importance of you know he who knows only
his side of the argument knows little of
that and and the importance of being
able to exist in the realm of ideas and
then frankly it's just a an easy cheap
tactic to win arguments without winning
arguments because if I can attack you
for being a sis hat white male I don't
actually have to deal with the fact that
you might have an ideological argument
that that Corners me or makes me
uncomfortable in my own
predispositions what are some of the
mechanisms for enforcing cancellation
that people might not realize are part
of the cancellation
machine I would say one thing that
people seem not to talk enough about is
how early it's starting and especially
in the in the social media age I grew up
I had an iPhone when I was 10 or maybe
11 I was on Instagram by the time I was
11 surely and I am now like the human
receptacle for every parents horror
stories about what's happening to their
middle schoolers getting cancelled for
like a two-c Snapchat video or someone
screenshotted something and now
everyone's seen it and I think that one
of the enforcement mechanisms going
forward in the age of everybody having
this insanely excessive digital
footprint and all of their adolescent
blunders being forever immortalized in a
way that I think any older person should
shudder at the thought of um that's one
way that it's being enforced is that
there's an entire generation of young
people who were coming up just
surrounded by trip wires even in their
teenage years that they're arriving on
campus in college already primed for the
fact that they have to self-censor or
that they could be called out at any
point in time and I think that that's
self-perpetuating because that's making
less and less people even want to stick
their neck out in the first place but
then I also think that cancel culture is
is so dangerous and so powerful not just
for the people whose lives are torn down
and completely ruined but also for all
the people around them that see that and
see them having been made an example of
and then will refuse and understandably
so To Tread that same
territory what's that what's it called
like a a a some kind of ideological bias
test that people get asked uh and it's
almost like the culpably deniable
test of of becoming working out where
your politics are it's not part of some
uh induction it's not even part of a
code of conduct but people are just
sometimes throw a little question like
what do you think about Jordan Peterson
like have you ever listened to Ben
Shapiro have you done know this thing
and that's one of the more sort of soft
introduction ways to this that slowly
over time results in you being
denigrated at or or disparaged or made
to feel other and um yeah it's not just
people calling for removal of accounts
and bans and protests it's there seems
to be sort of a softer kind of
alienation of people that have different
views which importantly is culpably
deniable right there's no point at which
you've done the thing because I think
that people who are seduced by the
prospect of being a white knight or who
like the idea of performative empathy
because it makes them look more whilst
having to do nothing moral or people who
just want to enact power and enforce
this over other
people the game is beginning to evolve
in the way that memes often do where if
you it's now low status to be seen as
someone that calls for cancellation
because cancellation itself has become a
meme so now the methods of cancellation
need to become increasingly subtle they
need to develop as the defense
mechanisms develop as well yeah I mean I
think it's it's I think we've seen
coordinated sort of Twitter mob tear
Downs although I would say that 2020 was
kind of a an exception to that but to
your to your example um or to your point
an example of that would be in 2020 and
after the death of George Floyd if you
didn't post the black Square then that
was a a moral the ideological Ro shock
test yeah exactly and I mean there were
people who I I have friends who were
completely castigated and and and
unfollowed and blocked for not having
done so I I mean I didn't do it and that
wasn't didn't go over too well at NYU um
but that would be the perfect example of
like a a soft like do you buy into to
the prevailing ideology at that point in
time um and I would also say to that
point there's definitely like a a slow
and subtle quarantining that I saw of
when I was in um in classes at NYU and
in my more philosophy oriented courses
where it would kind of become clear that
maybe one or two people are a little
more heterodox and it was just like a
slow people are going to start kind of
sitting on the other side of the
classroom when they come in if that
person's over there um to the point
where it was like this kind of bubble as
though we were ill or there was
something wrong with us um and I I've
also watched how growing up that way has
I think polarized young people even more
because if you grow up if you're being
racially segregated when you're 14 on
Martin Luther King Jr day and you're
having political ideologies shut down
your throat from pretty much day one
it's understandable why some people
especially young people become the
reactionary opposite or can go down some
rabbit hole on the internet um and like
I I'm fascinated to see I'm sure you saw
that statistic that um girls and boys
are like forking politically right now
and I think there's what do you make of
that um I you know I think
it's I think part of it is a little bit
of a reactionary thing for boys and
understandably so I think that I
I tacked right when I saw how weird the
left was around me when I was in school
but I also feel like politics
are like there's almost a feminization
of the left a little bit and a lot of
um I think a lot of even cancel culture
or or attitudes about free speech and
and needing to protect other people from
harmful speech almost hijack the the
female proclivity to be more empathetic
or or to um you know emotional Ally
reason more than rationally reason which
is obviously you know you do the whole
like on average and of course there are
exceptions to that rule but I mean even
if you look at students attitude on free
speech and the percentages of students
at various schools who will say that
it's sometimes acceptable to respond to
speech with violence
consistently like the top five schools
are all all women's schools with the
highest percentage of people saying that
they would respond with violence to
speech and so I do think that
our political binary is taking on a
little bit of a gendered tone and then
you also just have the the reality of
growing up on the internet and ending up
down rabbit holes which happened to me
politically and I was like all the way
on the right one year and then all the
way on the left one year and it's it's
understandable how how that could cause
a polarization I think for sure have you
looked at Corey Clark's work do you know
who she is name sounds familiar but
evolutionary psychologist phenomen Al
and she sent an email to every
psychology lecturer in America she
contacted them all to ask about uh
Trends around self-censorship
specifically looking at what sorts of
topics this put it in the second book
it's so she's so great uh she was on the
show a couple of months ago and um
consistently female teachers skew
towards there are certain things that
shouldn't be spoken about there are
harsher judgments that should be for the
lecturers that do talk about this sort
of stuff and shock horror the two areas
that were the most uh derogated the ones
that you shouldn't talk about behavioral
genetics and evolutionary psychology why
well because there are immutable facts
or it posits that there are immutable
facts and sex denialism or sex
difference denialism has no place to
slot in in either of those
worldviews yeah that's interesting and
also to that um effect fire will ask
students what issues are like the
touchiest on campus that they feel that
they can't speak about and consistently
they're the most important political
issues of the day which is super
disturbing like in 2020 all of a sudden
it was racial issues and then this year
um affirmative action was like all the
way at the top and the Israel Palestine
conflict is always up there and it's
like the things that you would most want
a college campus to be the Forum of
different ideas colliding in a in
a an intellectual and robust and healthy
way it's the ideas that are the the most
touchy of transgender issues are always
at the very top or post row was uh the
issue of abortion and it's it's it's
super disturbing to see that the things
that you'd most want to have kids hash
out or at least hear and understand
competing viewpoints on are consistently
the ones at the bottom of the Barrel in
terms of what they're actually willing
to touch as well well forget the fact
this is important to the development of
a brain that's trying to work out what's
true in the world they're the most
interesting things
M they're the ones that that that are
actually interesting to talk about you
decide totically seal off a bunch of
different things and you're left with
stuff that no one has a really strong
opinion on or that no one can become
offended by and you go well by
definition those things aren't very
passion inducing they're not exciting to
talk about so I think back to you know I
went to UNI 2006 and I was at Newcastle
uh for five years so I did two degrees
while I was there there wasn't a single
point while I was there where politics
even came in I was doing a business
degree I was regularly in lecture
theaters with 250 or 300 students and
there wasn't a single time when it came
in what it was pre me too so I guess you
know there was some reckonings kind of
around social justice and male behavior
and male female sex Dynamics and and and
politics as well you know it's it's
pre-trump it's pre largely pre- social
media Facebook was available the that I
went if you only had a a University
email address that was when it was still
gatee kept by having a University email
address it was only for people that
attended like accredited institutions or
whatever but that it my experience at
University despite being mostly boring
was completely bereft of any uh control
like we were degenerate Club promoters
and and like Jim Bros so I guess we may
have disregarded them had they've been
there in any case but I didn't notice
any of this and it makes me it makes me
sad it makes me sad to think
that I I still have faith and I still
believe that University is a very good
formative experience because I look at
the transformation that I went through
absolutely 100% of it outside of the
lecture theater but I look at all of the
changes that I went through and I think
if I hadn't had that I would it would
have taken me significantly longer to
have got to the stage where I was
socially uh in terms in terms of my life
experience in terms of my networking
ability in terms of how much business
experience I got all of those things it
was like a you know a crash course Navy
SEAL hell week of just learning to be
around other people and losing your keys
and getting drunk and having an argument
with a friend at 3 in the morning all of
the experiences outside of the
University thing were important but if
every single one of them is colored with
this like sword of damic that's hanging
over your head in case you say the wrong
thing and now the fact that you do have
a gullible surveillance state co-opted
by volunteers that don't realize they're
doing it like someone has CCTV footage
at all times we had this idea this is
like the least academic insight into uh
the proliferation of smartphones back in
the day we used to do a t-shirt Barrow
called Carnage and this was 2007 2008
2009 it was a license to print money you
put one of these things out and it just
sold out immediately and there was tasks
on the back things like pulled a pig got
off with three randoms shop swapped
shoes with somebody people would write
the first half of the alphabet down the
the right side of their arm and the
second half down the left side of their
arm and they'd try and kiss one person
from each letter of the alphabet like
this is classic Mid naughties American
Pi style like University
Behavior but one of the questions I
asked a friend was like where did that
sort of Larry British sort of student
culture go and he said as soon as the
smartphone came around no one could make
mistakes on a night out without fearing
that it would Define them for the rest
of their life that you have you know you
kissed some person that's like uncool or
embarrassing or whatever you do it in
2006 people laugh about it and then it's
either forgotten about or you can deny
it outright and do whatever but in the
age of the Internet it's you know
cemented online for the rest of time and
it defines you absolutely I mean and I
think that the impacts on young people
are so much more profound than we've
even really started to talk about I mean
I'm 23 and I'm just at like the the
beginning of just burgeoning into
adulthood and being the first cohort of
people who are able to reflect back on
what it means to have an a Smartphone
when you're 10 and to have the threat of
anything popping up at any point in time
and any anyone born post 2000 who tells
you that they don't have something
unsavory somewhere that they would
rather not have come back to haunt them
is absolutely lying to you I think we're
ultimately going to a ceasefire on this
front because it's going to get so bad
we're never going to have a politician
who um Can Survive Oppo research for the
rest of time now that we've been so
overly online and I think the the sad
thing to me is that young people
demonstrably know this like I the amount
of of concern that I've heard from my
peers and and from from people reaching
out to me about their own children um
and also the the polling if you ask
Generations what what their view is of
cancel culture positive or negative the
most positive view is Millennials and
then it gets more negative as as you get
older except for jenzi completely
reverses that Trend so even though
Millennials have the most positive view
of cancel culture jenzi has the most
negative view even more negative than
Boomers because we grew up with it like
we grew up looking behind our shoulders
but the problem is it's a very small
squeaky wheel minority of Our Generation
that is at the helm of these cancel
campaigns and we'll like Twitter shame
their boss but the rest of us have not
been given the the restorative kind of
free speech oriented classical liberal
set of values to supplant cancel culture
we just know we don't like this but
we're not quite sure how to fix it or
put her finger on it or stop attacking
people at hominum and and living in the
realm of ideas so I think there's a a
tremendous amount of anxiety and unrest
and being a young person who grows up
unable to
make social faux paws as everyone does
when they're an adolescent or you know
have their Marxist phase and then
realize a couple months later that that
wasn't for them but that's part of
growing up and exploring and you know I
think um young people just really have
not been taught the the values required
to um interact in the intellectual world
with the the epistemic humility of
realizing that you might be wrong at any
point in time and that anyone that you
talk to knows something that you don't
know um and that your opinions aren't
part of your personhood and and
extending that same um generosity and
Grace to somebody who you might be
disagreeing with um and I think that's
really profound and I also um just to go
back to what you were saying on the on
the University front like I'm I dropped
out of NYU with a 4.0 GPA not because I
have some sort of disain for education
and learning but the really sad reality
at that point in time and such an
ideologic IC Al homogeneous environment
was that I had to drop out for my love
of learning in defense of it and it's
not because I don't believe in the
importance of education but I think in
its current form it is so distorted and
these institutions of of higher
education have just appointed themselves
the sole Gatekeepers to success and
poate society and have had absolutely no
Market pressure placed upon them and
it's going to require more young people
proving that it's not the only Pathway
to success to actually I think Shake um
Society from its complacency and
challenge these institutions to actually
be better and to serve people who are
their
patrons talk to me about the
relationship between Free Speech laws
and Free Speech
culture yeah I think that this is one of
um the most interesting insights from
the book where you know there are three
countries with extremely robust Free
Speech laws on the books which aside
from the us almost to if you were to
read them you might think that it's the
first amendment and they are turkey
North Korea and Russia so having a free
speech law on the books means absolutely
nothing if your culture in practice does
not abide by them whereas on the flip
side one of the most vibrant points in
intellectual history was the French
Enlightenment at a point in time where
there was absolutely no legal protection
for free speech on the books at all
whatsoever but because there was a a
salon culture and a a culture in which
at were interested in the free exchange
of ideas and leaning into intellectual
Society Free Speech was able to flourish
and I think that it's really important
to realize that merely having the First
Amendment on the books or merely having
its equivalent on the books in another
country is not adequate to actually
fostering a culture that operates in a
free speech way um and there's a a great
quote by a judge named Learned Hand
which does not really sound like a real
name to me but and I'll bungle it but
roughly um roughly the quote is that you
know Liberty lives in the in the hearts
and minds of of every man and woman and
if it lies there it doesn't need a court
or a law to protect it but if it dies
there no court or law can save it and I
think that we're seeing this slow and
subtle cultural shift away from Free
Speech Norms that all of a sudden like
throw social media in the mix and you
can burn any heretic at the Stak and
it'll happen like that because it's it's
really hard to grow up in the west today
and realize just how crazy it is that we
don't burn our Heretics at the stake in
the scheme of human history we live in
like the Teeny tiniest little sliver of
time where we actually don't do that but
all of a sudden now we're doing it in
the digital sphere because that is
Mankind's Instinct and so just having a
law on the books doesn't really matter
unless everyone Buys in and actually
abides by the the cultural code that
that it is really
required there was a really interesting
Insight I saw from the New York Post
article that you guys did where it was
talking about how Free Speech culture
and ideological diversity can make the
world more chaotic and because most
humans don't like this a good contingent
of those people will happily trade their
freedom for increased predictability
that if you're exposed to new opinions
and ideas that don't conform with you
you have to confront the fact that maybe
you're wrong and you know accepting that
you are wrong to the ego is tantamount
to destruction it's almost an
invalidation of you entirely oh my God
if I'm wrong about this what else might
I be wrong about and this denial of ever
having to admit that we're wrong
especially in a world where everything
that we do and say is permanently
cemented on the internet for all of time
to people to scrutinize I thought that
was very interesting and I I think from
my perspective that seems to be right a
more chaotic world with a mult
multiplicity of ideological viewpoints
and diversity of opinion
is unsettling in many ways to people and
they will happily
trade the accuracy and the truthfulness
uh and the freedom that they have in
order to increase the reliability and
predictability that they have about the
world going
forward yeah absolutely and I think that
that's made even worse by the fact that
polarization has I think made politics
so much more tied to individual identity
than it has been in the past as well so
an assault on your ideas feels like an
assault on you as a person and I think
also to the the point of chaos I mean if
we if we look back historically we're in
the very beginning ages of what it means
to now have billions of people in the
cultural conversation thanks to social
media it's you know been roughly a
decade since it's been
invention of the printing press and when
the printing press was invented Henry
VII was trying to license who can print
a a pamphlet and there were hundreds of
years of religious wars as a result and
that was a really chaotic and
uncomfortable time where I think it's
actually pretty understandable why the
powers that be and the people that were
beholden to them wanted to squash out
all the new voices that entered the
cultural conversation and challenged the
norms and we look back and we think well
that was a great thing and literacy
rates Rose and that created the
Enlightenment and the world as we know
it but we're still in that early kind of
chaos days of social media and I think
the fact that things haven't gotten
worse than they are at the moment is
actually kind of amazing um and and a
testament to the fact that there are
still some people who do believe in in
free speech and and the wisdom of the
populace but um I I think like the
Twitter files just go to demonstrate how
how threatening new voices in a cultural
conversation can be to the social Fabric
and to um the kind of levers of
society what do you say to the people
who claim this isn't cancellation
culture this is consequence culture this
is just people being brought to account
for having heinous reprehensible
views I mean I think that the the swath
of views that have become cancelable
offenses has grown so considerably I
mean we just have like case after case
in our book of um there's there's one
and Carol hoen who was a Harvard
Professor who God forbid one on Fox News
and she and she's lovely and she's
tactful and she's careful with her words
and she went on Fox News um to discuss
some issue of gender she wrote the book
T um about testosterone and she
extremely tactfully said you know we can
respect people's gender identity and use
their pronouns however we have to also
acknowledge the fact that biological sex
is real and on a on a fundamental level
and for that she was effectively
squeezed out of her job to the point
where and I know you know this story but
to the point where she she told us um in
an interview for the book that she was
actually um suicidal for the first time
in her life and so if the the group of
cancelable offenses is now including
acknowledging biological reality as a
professor in your own field um or you
know going all the way down to now
middle schoolers that whose parents call
me constantly and and reach out to me or
email me um to say that their seventh
grader has now been canceled for
something which I mean it's SE in
seventh grade that just shouldn't even
you shouldn't even be politically aware
you're worried about boys and acne and
not politics at that point in time um
and just the sheer number as well but if
it really were about accountability
culture I think the truth that a lot of
people who've witnessed these cancel
mobs form um Can attest to is the fact
that apologies do not make it better
it's not about saying oh I I did tweet
that 10 years ago but I completely
disagree with it now and I apologize for
offending you because that doesn't fix
it it's not actually about making people
account for the any error that they
might have made or any misstep it's
about making an example of them and
shaming them yeah it's having your
morality stand on the shoulders of
someone that you can easily accuse I
mean the Carol thing we went for
breakfast me her uh William Costello a
couple of months ago and uh that woman
cries more easily than anyone I've ever
met she's like the most empathetic I
think she cried six times on Rogan like
four times on my show she's just such a
touchy feely lovely person that's really
delicately trying to move through this
she's a really perfect example of
whatever we want to call it like um soft
mechanisms of cancellation because at no
point did anyone come to her and say you
can't teach anymore but every teaching
assistant that she was supposed to be
working with refused to help in her
class so if you don't have a teaching
assistant like how are you going to you
can't do your class and I think she had
one of the most popular it like quite a
well attended class at har so it's okay
well I guess I'm kind of like on the
bench for now and then when you're on
the bench for that so long you just end
up kind of falling away so and it's so
interesting to think that the the
apology doesn't make any difference
because if that was what you were after
then the apology would fix the problem
it's like hey interesting how
interesting I didn't know about this
particular statistic about this thing
because no one from an ideologically Pur
Purity spiral Spiral driven world can
believe that someone would be
sufficiently epistemically humble to
actually ever be able to say that it's
like no no no no this is you your
identity and your opinions and your
ideology are one and the same you know
we saw this with
Rogan the variety of cancellations that
he went through a couple of years ago
and what people do I thought it was
really
formative people try and say here is an
individual instance or a collection of
instances that may seem small here but
we know that they are representative of
this big iceberg that lies below the
surface this is the The Smoking Gun that
tells you that this person is the
bigoted racist transphobic homophobic
whatever thing that we always knew that
they were and this is this is finally
the crack the Fisher has shown through
this facade that they've created so all
right well what you had with Joe and
what you know increasingly I would like
to think people will see with other
online content creators or writers or
anybody all right well that might be
true but I also have 5,000 hours of him
talking to people on podcasts and it
didn't come up then so he's either the
best liar and and deflector of his
bigoted racist views in history or
that's
unrepresentative overall and I don't
know it seems to me like I would like to
think people give what used to be called
the benefit of the doubt but I don't
know that that seems to be increasingly
rare now yeah I mean I think that also
to that point the benefit of the doubt
is often given to anybody's like
ideological friends but then it's
precisely the opposite if they just
don't like someone instinctively um and
I I think you know it's been instructive
to see like Rogan survive cancellation
attempts and and Barry waste to make a
career out of it basically with the free
press and the awesome stuff that she's
doing there um or shipal and and seeing
Netflix finally actually toughen up and
and um say no to their employees that
were trying to wreak havoc over a single
joke I mean I do think that there have
been examples of of cancellation going
so far that there is a band of people
who are willing to come around and
actually support you and champ in you as
a result and I think that that Jo
organ's a perfect example of that um but
I you know I worry that those are only
people who are in a powerful enough
position when it first happens to them
that people know um and there's so many
just like unheard stories or even I I
think that one of the problems is like
on a college campus it's much easier to
quantify how often this is happening
because people often have legal recourse
but in in the private spheres it's
impossible for us to tally how many
people have been cancelled not only
because some people will just shut down
and never say anything but also because
there are so many examples of people who
will talk to you off the Record about it
but they've signed an NDA because that
was their their Severance agreement with
whatever company they were squeezed out
of um and you know um Jennifer SE who
left Levis she refused to sign an NDA
and and turned away a million dollars of
payout to um because she had criticized
covid policies and School lockdown
which apparently means that you can no
longer be an executive at Levis um but
you know she she refused to sign an NDA
and we only know that that even happened
because she she had the spine to
actually say no I want to maintain my
intellectual autonomy but um yeah I mean
I think that there's there's so many
high-profile tear Downs that thankfully
people are starting to land on their
feet and support one another but um you
know I fear that the 2024 election will
be another wave of all of the same stuff
and I I'm not feeling great about the
future of cancel culture in the near
future so oh yeah what what are your
predictions give me give me the weather
report moving forward for the Stormfront
of
cancellation yeah I think I am hugely
concerned about 2024 as is my co-author
um I I especially considering that we
have such polarizing options on both
sides of the aisle I'm I'm very
concerned that 2020 and
2016 were just like little trial runs
for
how how polarized and how at hominum
we're about to get um at least in the US
and I think that you know the the Ripple
effects of American politics are really
felt across at least the english-
speaking world and often just the
cultural West in general so I'm not
feeling fabulous about the near future
I'm extremely nervous as we seem to be
um kind of just powering ahead towards
an election between two
historically unpopular incumbents so um
I don't know I'm not feeling great but
what what are your predictions on on
that front do you think that the social
unrest is going to
continue it's a difficult one I would
guess yes
because the memes of production for
creating Trends online and going
completely super viral have become more
sophisticated like this is one of the
things that's interesting people look at
the algorithms on social media as if
they are the things that give us the
content but they also train the content
creators so if you think that the memes
that came out in 2016 were sophisticated
and built to limic hijack you and if you
thought that the things that happened in
2020 were oh my God like look at all of
this stuff wait until 2024 each time
that it comes back around there is a new
iteration of people and sometimes AI now
creating stuff that is even more
compelling that's even more outrage
inducing
so I don't know I'm in Texas so I feel a
little bit like I'm insulated from
anything sort of too crazy even being in
Austin people call it a blue dot in a
red ocean I've never seen any of the
blue dots here it just seems to be like
just a red ocean but um yeah it's it's
going to be it's going to be very
interesting
and I don't know it's so right to say
that most of the people that survived
their cancellations with people who
already had tons of momentum you know
Chappelle Rogan JK Rowling Etc um and
there's definitely a part
of some sides of the cancel mob picking
fights with people that they know can't
fully defend themselves you know like
Carol hoen again is a good example of
that like she's so kind it was obviously
going to emotionally impact her if
you're someone that even knows has even
seen five minutes of her on a podcast
you know that this isn't someone that's
going to come out of the gates swinging
like Dave P right it's someone who's to
be very impacted by this and also
doesn't have a million person Twitter
where they can Wrangle a huge audience
of people that come around and also like
what's the lesson to take away from that
everybody should have a huge mailing
list of email address everyone should
build up a massive substack as like a
break glassing case of cancellation
thing that's not
realistic yeah no absolutely I mean and
I think that
um I think that we're only seeing just
the beginning of of how profound that's
going to get I I worry about 24 I worry
about every single moment of cultural
unrest that we have going forward unless
we actually return to the values that
make a divers a diverse democracy
possible I think that um that's pretty
much impossible and we will end up going
towards a Marxist sort of divide and
conquer situation which makes enemies of
everyone unless we actually can start
looking at view point point and and
living in the realm of ideas and the
realm of of personhood in two separate
planes um and so I think until until we
really have a cultural Reckoning and it
gets really ugly which I think it's
coming in the near future um I don't
think that that things will get much
better but I'm curious you so Austin is
not as blue as as they say it is I don't
know if it's me just spending time with
lots of bigoted reprehensible people uh
like neuro diverent degenerates but they
seem to be they all seem to be like you
know relatively Free Speech relatively
open to new ideas um yeah I I haven't se
I mean there's like some stuff stop
having kids.org does like this goth
parade every year down Broadway there
was some stuff to do with like PR Lifey
things but that's not that's not because
it's BL that's just a a variety of
opinions being shown via Street protest
um what else have I seen there was a
pronatalism conference here two weeks
ago you know there's a lot of different
stuff going it doesn't seem to be very
heavily controlled um thinking about
that though you the complete
unlikeliness of people building up some
huge online platform so that they can
then deploy it to protect themselves in
case of being cancelled what are the
potential solutions to this Beyond make
it worse so everyone hates it more and
then it getss better are there any more
fluffy Solutions than that any less
apocalyptic ones of course um yeah so we
the the final section of our book is
Solutions oriented and I think um a lot
of it is just throwing everything at the
wall and hoping that something sticks
but we think that parenting is a large
portion of it um especially with young
people and that a lot of the um the the
sense that words can be violence and
wound you are the result of helicopter
parenting and and a um just complete
abandonment of the sort of ideas of anti
fragility that prior Generations were
raised with Jen Z was very coddled and
protected and made to be anxious and
feel as though they're feeble and um
endangered by the world around them and
my co-author um his previous book is the
coddling of the American mind which um
concentrated quite a lot on parenting
and its impact on politics and gen z um
and so we think that there's a lot about
leading by example as a parent and
raising kids who will not be cancellor
and understand their own vulnerability
as well as the vulnerability of their
friends um and I I do find a tremendous
amount of Hope in the fact that young
people are so put off by cancel culture
that if they were just given the
positive restorative framework to fight
back against it and um kind of a social
pact that would be mutually protective
that there's there's some hope there
going forward um we also think that
divesting away from the the elite
University system just being the only
way that people end up in in positions
of power in society is a healthy thing
um and that people who are hiring um
should consider kids coming from large
State schools and kids from different
backgrounds or people who didn't finish
college or people who went down a
different path and that we shouldn't
just have this funnel of kids coming
from consistently the the most elite
schools or the schools with the worst
attitudes towards Free Speech which I
think it's no surprise that we're seeing
uh absolute chaos erupting on campuses
like Harvard right now because if you
abdicate free speech and you suppress
students and and send bad ideas
underground for decades on end all of a
sudden in a moment of cultural unrest
they're going to explode and that's
precisely what we're seeing right now um
and so we believe that you know opening
our minds to alternative education
systems and not allowing these schools
that seem to breed cancel culture and
counselors to you know take the Reigns
of society consistently with every
graduate class that's a positive um and
also even people who are running
corporations uh can I think take one
note out of Netflix's book after The J
Dave Chappelle controversy where they
said you know if you can't tolerate the
fact that we are going to publish
viewpoints that you disagree with as as
a platform for ideas and expression then
you can leave um I think that's that was
a remarkably unique and brave stance to
take and actually coinbase did that um a
while ago their CEO Brian Armstrong was
like we're just not going to make any
institutional statements and if that's a
problem for you you can go and like 10%
of their employee base did actually go
but like that's not the 10% of people
that you want to work for you so I think
um on the the level of Corporations we
can um I think there are a lot of we
hear frequently Greg and I both from
corporate leaders who are terrified of
their like 23-year-old tires and that's
just such a bizarre power imbalance and
it's very
fixable if you just create a free speech
culture from the GetGo but I also think
weirdly um after October 7th there's a
lot of people rediscovering the
importance of institutional neutrality
and of free speech and free expression
and you know it's I think it's a really
revealing moment for schools to suddenly
say oh you know we had a statement about
Kyle written House's aquid and BLM and
all these completely irrelevant things
to the interworkings of a university but
we can't make a statement on this of
course I think it's it's shocking that
this is the moment that they finally
discovered that institutions are full of
people with viewpoints and do not have
viewpoints themselves but maybe there's
a silver lining that this moment of just
absolute chaos in in institutions where
Free Speech was not valued for so long
where they're suddenly hiding behind the
veence of free speech like maybe this is
where we actually buy in and we realize
we're all vulnerable in a world where a
liberalism is allowed to re
Supreme what would you say as a piece of
advice to someone who is threatened with
cancellation or is going through it have
you got a A Todo and not to-do checklist
for those
people yeah I think um obviously it's
it's so dependent on the level of
supportive people around you but I think
the most important thing for
everyone who is concerned about cancel
culture to say now as as an individual
before anything happens to them or
anyone that they know is that if someone
that you know and care about and like is
attacked you commit that you will stand
up for them it's not that I I agree with
their viewpoint but they're a good
person and tearing them down is not the
right thing to do and I think that if we
afford that to other people that um and
hopefully expect that in return from
them if the the mob comes for us that's
one way to fight back I think the power
of someone else standing up for you is
really
profound and unfortunately cancel
culture thrives because everyone else is
scared to stick their neck out there and
like when I was writing about free
speech at NYU for the New York Post
which is not really the most popular
thing to do surprisingly um you know I
have so many people messaging me and
saying oh I completely support you and I
completely agree with you but just don't
tell anyone that we had this
conversation and that that's got to stop
and we have to Short Circuit this but on
the front of if you actually are
targeted with a cancel culture attempt
it's funny this is actually a point
where my co-author and I have a little
bit of disagreement where he says never
apologize under any circumstances period
And I don't fully agree with that I
think if it's something that you would
apologize to a friend for or something
that you genuinely didn't mean I don't
think you apologize and try to Plate the
individual who's treating you unfairly
but if you genuinely don't agree with
the tweet that you sent when you were 14
because who does then I think you say
that's not me but I don't think that you
ever try to Plate the mob that's the
number one thing is if someone is
attacking you unfairly you don't try to
respond to that with with undo
rationality when or ever compromise and
apologize for something that you don't
actually feel any remorse for for sure
Ricky schlot ladies and gentlemen where
should people go they want to keep up to
date with the things that you're doing
where should they go on the internet um
my Twitter is just my name Ricky schlot
and Ricky SCH slot.com and um I think
probably by the time this comes out I'll
be launching a new podcast um under Bill
Mars umbrella Club random so um that
will be forthcoming in
2024 very cool I enjoy the prospect of
you joining me in the muck and the Meer
of the podcasting
world I am super excited to I've been
learning from you doing all my homework
uh waking up to Modern wisdom so thank
you my pleasure I really appreciate you
thank you for today if you enjoyed that
episode then here for a selection of the
best clipss from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe